hey guys my name is anna kate i'm 19. i
live in fullerton california
i think i have the same issue as bobby
and steve uh that's bobby's brother
every night before i go to bed i have to
tap on my headboard three times before i
go to sleep
because if i don't do it i always think
something bad will happen too yeah yeah
yeah i've always felt my whole life i
would say things in my head and be
telling myself to do something and if i
don't do it my dog
would die or anything like that but just
recently i've been doing the headboard
tapping thing
i want to know what you guys think this
is or if you found a way to stop it i
think it might be an ocd thing it is
it is and i still do it and it what i do
is um
like well here's the thing that if i
if her and i are watching something on
this is a new one we're watching
something on
you know on the ipad or whatever and
there's a scene
in my head immediately you got to rewind
it two more times and watch it over
again
interesting and i've done that before
right
on when we watched a movie or whatever
but now what i've been doing
is just fighting it what's the thought
though that if you don't do it what
happens like what's that my mom's gonna
implode or interesting so i i do the
same things as well like
um but i don't have the whole like uh
something bad will happen i just have to
do it like
uh what i do is um like today for
example
well i guess it was kind of to prevent
something bad from happening i was in my
garage and for some reason the garage
door
the parking garage the uh the door
opened
when no one was there and i'm like what
the hell so then and you know you think
like oh what if like
a weird spirit or something i don't know
so then i always say uh buddha bless me
in shanghainese three times
um i always do that like uh
i just do it real quick you know what i
mean like yeah um and same with the
the rewindy stuff i'm not kidding
literally like i'll do that
or especially if i miss something real
quick even though i know it's probably
an insignificant sentence that the actor
just said right but i have to go back
because
what if it's important or like it'll
kill me it'll bug me for the rest of my
days
um especially when i was little oh even
now i still do a thing where i can't
um do things in four or even six
uh so like if i drink something i cannot
have four gulps
if i have four gulps i have to go for a
fifth gulp
you're like him you go for the odd
numbers because he's an odd number kind
of yeah something
but what i've been doing is i'm letting
it pass
so in my head i'll go rewind it two more
times right
or whatever and i'll go
you're not doing it and even for the
next hour i'll be thinking about it
oh wow no it's interesting but it'll
pass it'll pass
i have um what i have is a little bit
different it's more of like a physical
comfort thing
i think it stems from well that's not
true i was an athlete my whole life you
know what she does
flex that was a super flex i was a
really good athlete
wait what's sport nationals
the philippine team oh my goodness it's
legit i wish i had a swimmer's body i
don't i have a sleeper's body
you're a floater's body yes honey i'm a
sinker's body
i'm flattered do you think i float yeah
but um yeah so
i think all athletes have their stupid
little superstitions and stuff but what
i have to do that drives him
absolutely crazy is because i i have to
sprinkle my feet with water before
um i sleep or every time i use a toilet
every time i use a toilet i have to go
to the sink and then i have to sprinkle
whoa i'm laying in bed i imagine it's
dark right
and there's like you know i i see her
silhouette in the bathroom
right i see her put on the you know i
mean
my feet and in my head i'm like is she
gonna
kill me that's crazy i can't go to sleep
wow
i don't feel comfortable i don't feel
refreshed i don't feel like
connected to myself if i don't have wet
feet do you hop
in the bed with wet feet um by the time
it's just sprinkles right so by the time
i
walk over that it's already um dry
there's no drying station it's like a
car wash
um wait interesting interesting
interesting i don't think it's ocd it
has nothing to do with that i just i
mean
it's a comfort thing that i i'm used
it's a ritual sure
sure i mean because i also
i'm weird in the sense where i i come
out of the shower
and go straight into my slides
because what kind of slides though the
nike
you know how some people go into like
the cotton slides oh
no like the fluffy ones i'm like no
never go
wet into fluff do you do you dry in the
shower or outside the shower i dry the
feet because i'm going straight into the
chunk glass yeah
and uh i love how you call them chunks i
dry no i dry outside i guess
okay yeah yeah do you ever sit in bed
with a wet towel or
forbidden um sometimes i do i sleep
there for hours with a towel on my head
drives my sister crazy let's go back to
this poor guy oh i'm sorry
let her [ __ ] pass the point is you
are not alone yeah yeah and you're not
alone and let it [ __ ] pass
you don't do it yeah don't think too
much into it either because if it's not
like disrupting your life in general
yeah because like i think what happens
is that people are so quick to throw the
ocd
ocd is a really serious thing right it
disrupts people's
joy and life right on a daily basis so
if it's something small like that
take note of it but don't add too much
sauce on it
also accept the consequence that you
think is gonna
if you think if you think if i don't do
this i'm gonna die
my thinking now is let me die then yeah
let's prove myself wrong yeah
i'll [ __ ] die i'm not doing this this
is crazy yeah i'm not touching that
thing three times
no it's insane it's it's honestly so
interesting yeah yeah i don't have that
thought of like if i don't do it i'll
die though
i just have a like i just gotta do it i
gotta [ __ ] do it
what's his name uh he has no name oh i
thought it was a na you said a name oh
sorry anna anna it's a girl
it's a girl and i beat three tabs three
tap anna i like it
yeah what else do you want to promote
something else
just watch good trouble you know follow
me on instagram sherry cola
yeah yeah i love you so much for having
me terrified
verified honey the blue check the blue
check i'm